vítej zpět u kurzu Pochopení kvantové informace a výpočtů, jmenuji se John Watrous a jsem technický ředitel pro vzdělávání v IBM
Quantum. Toto je 10. lekce série a druhá lekce třetí jednotky, která se věnuje obecné
formulaci kvantové informace. Tato lekce je o kanálech, které reprezentují změny v
systémech uchovávajících kvantovou informaci. Patří sem užitečné operace, jako jsou ty prováděné
unitárními gate a kvantovými circuit, ale i změny, kterým bychom raději předešli, jako je šum. Můžeme také popisovat měření
jako kanály, a to je něco, čemu se budeme věnovat v příští lekci. Pojem kanál pochází z
teorie informace, která mimo jiné studuje kapacitu přenosu informace přes zašuměné komunikační
kanály. Když tedy přemýšlíme o kanálech, přemýšlíme abstraktně o komunikačních
kanálech. Může se zdát trochu zvláštní uvažovat o složitém výpočtu jako o komunikačním kanálu, ale potřebujeme
slovo pro obecný pojem procesu, který nějakým způsobem mění informaci, a ať se to líbí nebo ne, slovo
kanál se ujalo, nepochybně z velké části díky enormnímu dopadu teorie informace, a zejména
práce Clauda Shannona ze 40. let, na kvantovou informaci a výpočty. Zde je přehled
lekce: začneme základy včetně definice toho, co je kanál, a také tím, jak lze unitární operace v zjednodušené formulaci
kvantové informace popsat jako kanály. Budeme také hovořit o tom, že konvexní kombinace kanálů jsou kanály, a pokud
se ptáš, proč se tento pojem konvexity stále opakuje, je to proto, že jde skutečně o fundamentálně důležitý matematický pojem v teorii
kvantové informace. Uvidíme také některé příklady kanálů, konkrétně qubit kanály, které se budou znovu objevovat
v průběhu zbytku lekce. Ve druhé části lekce budeme hovořit o třech různých způsobech, jakými lze kanály reprezentovat
matematicky, a zejména budeme hovořit o Stinespringových reprezentacích, Kraussových reprezentacích a Choi
reprezentacích, které jsou pojmenovány po třech lidech, jejichž práce byla důležitá pro rozvoj těchto různých reprezentací. Ve třetí a
závěrečné části lekce probereme matematický důkaz, který stanovuje, že tyto tři reprezentace jsou ve skutečnosti ekvivalentní, a také to, že
všechny správně charakterizují definici toho, co je kanál. Je to podle mého názoru opravdu skvělý matematický důkaz a doufám, že přidá trochu
jasnosti těmto různým prezentacím, jak spolu souvisejí a jak obecně fungují. Začneme základy a
zodpovíme otázku: co jsou kanály? Jak jsem již naznačil na začátku lekce, kanály popisují změny,
konkrétně diskrétní časové změny v systémech uchovávajících kvantovou informaci. Když zde mluvíme o diskrétní časové
změně, myslíme tím pouze změnu, která nastává mezi dvěma odlišnými okamžiky v čase, na rozdíl od
spojitého procesu, o němž dává smysl uvažovat přes nekonečně malé časové úseky. Kanály zahrnují užitečné operace, jako jsou
unitární operace prováděné kvantovými gate a circuit, ale i změny způsobené šumem. Pro
účely této lekce však budeme o kanálech přemýšlet většinou v abstraktních matematických pojmech a nebude třeba
rozlišovat mezi tím, co je užitečné a co ne. Typickými názvy pro kanály jsou velká řecká písmena fí,
psí a ró a k označení některých konkrétních kanálů budeme používat různá písmena. V jednoduché situaci, kdy
máme systém ve stavu popsaném hustotní maticí ró a aplikujeme na tento systém kanál fí, je
výsledkem systém, jehož stav je popsán hustotní maticí fí z ró. Takže uvažujeme o daném
kanálu fí jako o funkci, která může být aplikována na hustotní matice určité velikosti, neboli jinými slovy
na hustotní matice určitého systému, na který tento kanál aplikujeme. Existuje několik požadavků, které musejí kanály splňovat, aby byly
považovány za platné kanály. Za prvé, kanály jsou lineární zobrazení. To je zcela analogické se situací, kterou máme
v zjednodušené formulaci kvantové informace, kde operace na kvantových stavových vektorech jsou nutně lineární,
a se standardní formulací klasické informace, kde jsou pravděpodobnostní operace lineární. Mohl bys zpochybnit tento základní
požadavek linearity, kdybys opravdu chtěl, ale pokud chceme teorii, která je konzistentní s teorií pravděpodobnosti
a s volbou reprezentovat kvantové stavy hustotními maticemi, nemáme vlastně jinou možnost a musíme prostě přijmout, že kanály jsou lineární.
Druhým požadavkem je, že kanály transformují hustotní matice na hustotní matice. To dává dokonalý smysl, protože pokud jsme se rozhodli reprezentovat
stavy systémů hustotními maticemi a aplikujeme kanál na systém v nějakém stavu, musí být výsledek platným stavem, a tedy
reprezentovaným hustotní maticí. Je zde však jeden velmi důležitý bod a sice, že tento požadavek
musí platit nejen pokud aplikujeme kanál na izolovaný systém, jehož stav je popsán hustotní maticí,
ale také pokud máme složený systém, jehož stav je popsán nějakou hustotní maticí, a aplikujeme kanál pouze na
část tohoto systému. To jsou tedy požadavky, které na kanály klademe, a vidíme, že jsou velmi
analogické s požadavky na operace v zjednodušené formulaci kvantové informace i ve standardní formulaci
klasické informace. V zjednodušené formulaci kvantové informace jsou operace reprezentovány unitárními maticemi, protože
přesně odpovídají lineárním zobrazením, která vždy transformují kvantové stavové vektory na kvantové stavové vektory pro daný
systém. Podobně jsou pravděpodobnostní operace reprezentovány stochastickými maticemi, protože to jsou ty, které
vždy transformují vektory pravděpodobnosti na vektory pravděpodobnosti. Zde pracujeme s hustotními maticemi a existuje
tento přidaný požadavek týkající se složených systémů, který se ukáže jako nepotřebný pro kvantové stavové vektory
nebo vektory pravděpodobnosti, ale jinak jsou požadavky analogické a v jistém smyslu jsou nám vnuceny volbou
reprezentovat kvantové stavy hustotními maticemi. Zde jsou některé další podrobnosti o kanálech, včetně konvence
pro to, jak budeme přemýšlet o vstupních a výstupních systémech kanálu v průběhu lekce, a také některé podrobnější informace
o požadavku, že kanály vždy transformují hustotní matice na hustotní matice. Za prvé, každý kanál má
předpokládaný vstupní systém a výstupní systém. Tyto systémy můžeme pojmenovat jak chceme, ale v průběhu
lekce budu používat název X pro vstupní systém a název Y pro výstupní systém. Pojmově řečeno, kanál
transformuje vstupní systém na výstupní systém, takže vstupní a výstupní systémy nikdy nesouběžně koexistují.
Začínáme s X, kanál je aplikován nebo proveden a výsledkem je, že X byl transformován na Y, jehož stav je
určen lineárním zobrazením spojeným s kanálem. Vstupní a výstupní systémy kanálu nemusejí být stejné, a zejména
nemusejí mít stejný počet klasických stavů. Může však nastat, že vstupní a výstupní systémy jsou ve skutečnosti stejný systém, neboli jinými slovy
WEBVTT
X se rovná Y, v takovém případě si jednoduše představujeme, že fí mění stav systému, a to je skutečně
velmi často situace, která nás zajímá, ale tato možnost je konzistentní s prvním bodem v tom smyslu, že nikdy nemáme
vstupní a výstupní systémy existující jako dva oddělené systémy ve stejnou dobu. V každém případě bude pro
účely této lekce vhodné používat různá písmena, konkrétně X a Y, k označení vstupního a výstupního systému,
aby nám to pomohlo udržet pořádek. Nyní se podíváme trochu podrobněji na požadavek, že kanály vždy transformují hustotní
matice na hustotní matice. Předpokládejme, že do obrazu zavedeme nový systém Z.
Dáme klasické stavové sadě tohoto nového systému název gama. Nyní si představme, že vytvoříme nový složený systém ZX
skládající se z nového systému spolu se vstupním systémem X kanálu fí, a předpokládejme, že tento složený systém je
ve stavu popsaném hustotní maticí ró. Může jít o libovolný kvantový stav tohoto páru, ale ať je to jakýkoli stav,
je vždy možné vyjádřit hustotní matici ró ve tvaru zobrazeném na obrazovce, kde A i B
procházejí klasickou stavovou sadou gama a každé ró AB je nějaká matice, jejíž řádky a sloupce odpovídají jakékoli
klasické stavové sadě X. Tuto klasickou stavovou sadu v tomto okamžiku nemusíme pojmenovávat. Aby bylo jasno, každé ró AB není nutně
hustotní maticí samo o sobě, ale celá matice ró je nutně hustotní maticí. Když aplikujeme kanál fí na
systém X, transformuje se na Y, a tak nám zbývá pár ZY, a způsob, jakým určíme
stav tohoto páru po provedení fí pouze na X, je vyhodnocení lineárního zobrazení fí na každé z matic ró A.
Jiný způsob, jak to říci, je, že vezmeme tenzorový součin zobrazení fí s identickým zobrazením na čtvercových maticích s řádky a sloupci
odpovídajícími gama, a to zase odpovídá nedělání ničeho s tímto novým systémem Z. Jde o ekvivalentní
popis, který nevyžaduje zacházení do podrobností o tenzorových součinech zobrazení tohoto typu. Ty
fungují poměrně přímočarým způsobem analogickým k tomu, jak fungují pro vektory a matice. Jedním způsobem, jak si to představit vizuálně, je
bloková maticová reprezentace, a pokud uděláme zjednodušující předpoklad, že klasická stavová sada gama sestává z
celých čísel od 0 do N minus jedna pro nějaké kladné celé číslo M, pak je snadné zapsat vše
tak, jak je zobrazeno zde. A nyní, abych zopakoval požadavek, který klademe na fí, aby byl platným kanálem, musíme vždy získat hustotní
matici z tohoto procesu a to musí platit bez ohledu na to, jaký systém Z zvolíme, a také bez ohledu na
volbu ró za předpokladu, že jde o hustotní matici. To se může zdát jako poměrně přísný požadavek a může se také zdát
velmi obtížné ho ověřit. Ale jak uvidíme na konci lekce, ve skutečnosti to není tak přísné
ani obtížné k ověření, a zejména máme pěkné matematické charakterizace pro tuto podmínku,
které jsou propojeny s různými reprezentacemi, o nichž budeme mluvit trochu později v lekci. Nyní se podívejme na některé příklady kanálů,
počínaje celou kategorií kanálů zvaných unitární kanály. Jednoduše řečeno, jsou to unitární
operace, stejně jako je máme v zjednodušené formulaci kvantové informace, nahlížené jako kanály. Přesně řečeno, předpokládejme, že U je unitární
matice, která reprezentuje unitární operaci na systému X. V zjednodušené formulaci kvantové
informace bychom tuto matici násobili daný kvantový stavový vektor, abychom určili akci, kterou tato operace má na tento kvantový stav.
Způsob, jakým to funguje pro hustotní matice, je, že hustotní matici násobíme zleva pomocí U a zprava pomocí U
dagger. V matematických pojmech nazýváme tuto operaci konjugací maticí U. To je konzistentní s tím, že ket psí
bra psí je hustotní matice popisující stav reprezentovaný kvantovým stavovým vektorem psí, a je poměrně
snadné ověřit, že zejména pokud bychom provedli U na kvantovém stavovém vektoru ket psí, dostali bychom U krát ket psí a jeho
hustotní maticová reprezentace je dána tímto vektorem vynásobeným jeho konjugovaným transpozitem, což je U krát ket psí krát bra psí krát U
dagger při vyhodnocení konjugovaného transpozitu U krát ket psí. Způsob, jakým je tento kanál definován,
dává smysl pro čisté stavy, a kombinací s linearitou vidíme, že dává smysl pro hustotní matice obecně,
a to díky skutečnosti, že každou hustotní matici lze vyjádřit jako konvexní kombinaci čistých stavů. Tato
definice nám vždy dává platný kanál pro jakoukoli volbu unitární operace U. Zejména konjugace
unitární maticí tímto způsobem nemění stopu matice, a pokud konjugujeme jakoukoli pozitivně semidefinitní
matici jakoukoli maticí, dostaneme jinou pozitivně semidefinitní matici, a je poměrně snadné to odvodit
přímo z definice pozitivně semidefinitních matic. Hustotní matice jsou tedy vždy zobrazovány na hustotní
matice a vše to platí i tehdy, kdybychom U tenzorově vynásobili identitní maticí libovolné velikosti, což je ekvivalentní
aplikaci tohoto kanálu pouze na část složeného systému. Zde je velmi jednoduchý příklad unitárního kanálu: předpokládejme,
že U je samotná identitní matice. To je velmi zjevně platný kanál nazývaný identitní kanál. Nedělat
vůbec nic je jistě lineární operace, a pokud začneme s hustotní maticí a nic s ní neuděláme, bude
stále hustotní maticí, takže jde o platný kanál. Lidé používají různé symboly pro označení tohoto kanálu,
někdy je to přesně stejný symbol, jaký používáme pro identitní matici, což může být trochu matoucí, ale obecně to tak není. Zde používám
písmena ID jako zkratku pro identitu, abych předešel jakékoli záměně, a tento zápis je také docela běžný. Může se zdát jako
velmi nudný kanál, ale v kontextu přenosu informace je to ve skutečnosti dokonalý kanál, kde
příjemce dostane přesně to, co odesílatel posílá, což je obvykle to, co si v tomto kontextu přejeme. Dalším způsobem, jak
získat spoustu příkladů kanálů, je vzít konvexní kombinace kanálů, neboli jinými slovy je zprůměrovat
dohromady, a skutečnost, že to můžeme dělat, je důležitým aspektem kanálů. Abychom to vysvětlili podrobněji, začneme se dvěma kanály F0 a F1,
řekněme, spolu s reálným číslem P mezi 0 a jednou. Aby bylo jasno, předpokládáme, že tyto dva kanály mají
stejný vstupní systém, jímž je X, a stejný výstupní systém, jímž je Y. Nyní uvažujme, co se stane, pokud se rozhodneme
aplikovat první kanál F0 s pravděpodobností p a jinak s zbývající pravděpodobností 1 minus P aplikujeme
druhý kanál F1. Například bychom mohli náhodně zvolit bit s těmito pravděpodobnostmi a pak použít tento náhodný
bit k určení, který kanál aplikovat. Tím efektivně aplikujeme nový kanál, který bychom mohli nazvat psí,
daný konvexní kombinací dvou kanálů, se kterými jsme začali, a který můžeme vyjádřit tak, jak je napsáno
na obrazovce. Lineární kombinace lineárních zobrazení takto můžeme vždy vzít, a způsob, jakým je lineární
WEBVTT
kombinace lineárních zobrazení definována na daném vstupu, je taková, že vezmeme stejnou lineární kombinaci výstupů.
To může vypadat triviálně, ale dává to smysl: výstup, který z tohoto hypotetického scénáře dostaneme, je jednoduše vážený průměr
výstupů, které bychom dostali ze dvou původních kanálů. Přesto je to nový kanál a
pokud F0 a F1 byly skutečně platné kanály, pak toto nové zobrazení bude také platným kanálem. Jiný způsob, jak to říci
matematicky, je, že množina všech kanálů z daného vstupního systému do daného výstupního systému je
konvexní, a to je důležitá matematická vlastnost kanálů. Obecněji to můžeme dělat, pokud máme M kanálů F0 až FM minus jedna
spolu s vektorem pravděpodobností, který nám říká, jaká je pravděpodobnost pro každý kanál. Pak dostaneme nový kanál příslušným průměrováním kanálů,
takže v jistém smyslu jde o nevyčerpatelný zdroj nových kanálů. Například třída tzv. smíšených unitárních kanálů je to,
co dostaneme vzájemnými konvexními kombinacemi unitárních kanálů. Tedy pokud máme M unitárních matic U0 až UM minus
jedna, všechny stejné velikosti, spolu s vektorem pravděpodobností, a vezmeme vážený průměr kanálů
odpovídajících jednotlivým unitárním maticím, jak je zobrazeno zde na obrazovce, dostaneme kanál. Kanály,
které lze takto zapsat, se nazývají smíšené unitární kanály. Ne každý kanál je smíšeným unitárním kanálem, ne každý
kanál takto lze získat, ale dost často se vyskytují. Dále se podíváme na několik konkrétních
příkladů kanálů. To budou všechno příklady kanálů z jednoho qubit na jeden qubit, které se nazývají qubit
kanály. První z nich se nazývá qubit reset channel a myšlenkou je, že tento kanál resetuje qubit
do nulového stavu. Zde používáme velké řecké písmeno lambda k označení tohoto kanálu, a způsob, jak si zapamatovat, co tento kanál dělá, je
přemýšlet o Blochově sféře. Velké lambda trochu vypadá jako šipka ukazující nahoru a nulový stav je na vrcholu Blochovy sféry, takže je to, jako by
ukazoval na polohu výstupu. Matematicky je definován tak, že lambda z ró se rovná stopa ró krát ket 0 bra 0, takže
pokud ho vyhodnotíme na libovolné hustotní matici ró, dostaneme nulový stav jako hustotní matici. Je přirozené se ptát,
proč potřebujeme stopu. Nemohli bychom jednoduše definovat lambda z ró jako ket 0 bra 0 bez stopy ró před tím?
Odpověď na tuto otázku je ne. Kanály musejí být lineárními zobrazeními a bez stopy ró by nebylo lineární. Mějte také na paměti, že
někdy potřebujeme vědět, jak kanál funguje jako lineární zobrazení na vstupech, které nejsou hustotními maticemi. Například,
jak jsme viděli dříve, pokud chceme vědět, co kanál dělá, když ho aplikujeme na složený systém, musíme
vyhodnotit tento kanál na jednotlivých blocích větší blokové matice, a ačkoli celá bloková matice může být
hustotní maticí, jednotlivé bloky obecně nebudou. Podívejme se tedy přesně, co tento kanál dělá, když ho aplikujeme
pouze na část složeného systému, a konkrétněji, co dělá, když ho aplikujeme na jeden ze dvou qubitů tvořících
ebit. Přesně řečeno, předpokládejme, že A a B jsou qubity, které jsou jako pár v Bellovém stavu fí plus, a aplikujeme lambda
na první qubit A. Abychom zjistili, co se stane, nejprve vyjádříme stav fí plus jako hustotní matici a
pro účely tohoto příkladu použijme k tomu přímou notaci. Zde je stav fí plus jako kvantový stavový vektor a zde je to, co dostaneme, když
tímto vektorem vynásobíme jeho konjugovaný transpozit a vše rozvineme. Pak můžeme aplikovat kanál na první qubit a vyhodnotit, co dostaneme. Zde je
lambda aplikovaná na první qubit a zde je to, co dostaneme, když vyhodnotíme každý z výrazů. Stopa ket 0 bra 0 je jedna
a stejně tak stopa ket 1 bra 1, takže v těchto dvou případech je výstupem kanálu ket 0 bra 0, a to vysvětluje
tyto dva výrazy v odpovědi. Stopa ket 0 bra 1 je naproti tomu nula, stejně jako stopa ket 1 bra 0,
takže tyto dva výrazy se vyhodnotí na nulu a tedy nic nepřispívají k odpovědi. Nyní můžeme trochu zjednodušit
a výsledkem je nulový stav pro první qubit A a úplně smíšený stav pro
druhý qubit B. Všimni si zejména, že jsme nezískali stav plus pro B, což by nebyl nutně
špatný odhad, kdybychom nevěděli nic o hustotních maticích a jen se podívali na reprezentaci stavu kvantovým stavovým vektorem. Ale tak
tento kanál nefunguje a neexistuje žádný kanál, který by mohl fungovat tímto způsobem. Kanál lambda se nazývá qubit reset channel, ale
způsob, jakým funguje, je více jako vyhození vstupního qubitu do koše a nahrazení čerstvým qubitem v nulovém stavu. To je ale ve skutečnosti
jediný qubit kanál, který vždy vydává nulový stav. Zde je další příklad qubit kanálu, conhecido jako
úplně defázovací kanál. Tento je označen delta a funguje tak, že ponechá diagonální
prvky libovolné matice 2x2 beze změny a vynuluje mimediagonální prvky. Delta je řecký ekvivalent D v
latinské abecedě a D je zkratka pro diagonální, takže to je jeden způsob, jak si zapamatovat, co tento kanál dělá. Alternativně
můžeme tento kanál vyjádřit pomocí přímé notace, jak je zobrazeno na obrazovce. Aby bylo jasno, výstup
je vždy matice 2x2, takže zejména dvě nulové výstupy se vztahují k nulové matici 2x2. Toto se dělá
obvykle a viděli jsme to dříve v této sérii. Symbol nula se obecně, možná nejednoznačně, používá pro nulový
prvek čehokoli, o čem mluvíme, ať už jsou to skaláry, vektory, matice nebo cokoli jiného. Udělejme stejnou věc, jako jsme dělali dříve pro
qubit reset channel, a podívejme se, co se stane, pokud tento kanál aplikujeme na polovinu ebitu. Nastavení je stejné, takže to
přeskočím a výsledkem je stav zobrazený na obrazovce, což je v podstatě sdílený náhodný bit. Takže
tento kanál vlastně převedl ebit na dokonale korelovaný pár klasických náhodných bitů.
A to je konzistentní s obecnější interpretací tohoto kanálu: vynulováním mimediagonálních prvků hustotní matice
efektivně zahazujeme kvantovou část hustotní matice a zbývá nám diagonální hustotní matice, která reprezentuje
klasický pravděpodobnostní stav. Jiný způsob, jak o tom přemýšlet, je, že tento kanál reprezentuje dokonalý bezztrátový klasický kanál, který přenáší bit.
Pokud tedy vložíme nulový nebo jedničkový stav nebo konvexní kombinaci těchto dvou stavů do kanálu, přijde tento stav nezměněn. Pokud se ale pokusíme
vložit do něj kvantový stav jako například stav plus, kanál se zachová, jako by tento stav změřil standardním bázovým měřením a poté
přenesl klasický výsledek. Posledním příkladem qubit kanálu je úplně depolarizující kanál.
Tento kanál vždy vydává úplně smíšený stav, takže je v jistém smyslu podobný qubit reset channel,
jenomže dostaneme méně užitečný úplně smíšený stav místo inicializovaného qubitu. Přirozený způsob,
jak uvažovat o tomto kanálu, je, že reprezentuje extrémní formu šumu a co se qubit kanálů týče,
tak šumovitěji to opravdu nejde. Nemám žádné dobré mnemotechnické pomůcky k sdílení pro zapamatování, co tenhle dělá, kromě toho, že omega je poslední
písmeno řecké abecedy a někdy se spojuje s koncem všech věcí, a možná to je to, co se stane
WEBVTT
nakonec se všemi qubity. Pokud jde o šum, je to dost extrémní, ale jednou věcí, kterou můžeme udělat, je zvážit konvexní
kombinaci tohoto kanálu a identitního kanálu, třeba s malou pravděpodobností epsilon pro úplnou
depolarizaci. Jde o méně extrémní formu šumu, kde daný stav qubitu bude většinou ponechán beze změny, ale existuje
malá šance, že se stane úplně smíšeným. Geometricky si to lze představit jako mírné stažení Blochovy sféry ke středu.
Mimochodem, podobnou věc můžeme udělat s úplně defázovacím kanálem, abychom modelovali například proces dekoherence, kdy se věci
stávají mírně více klasickými díky nějakému procesu. To jsou tedy tři základní příklady qubit kanálů a
budeme se k nim vracet hlavně jako ke zdrojům příkladů v průběhu zbytku lekce. Dále probereme matematické
reprezentace kanálů, počínaje základní otázkou. Lineární zobrazení z vektorů na vektory lze vždy
reprezentovat maticemi obvyklým způsobem, kdy je akce lineárního zobrazení popsána maticovým
násobením vektoru. Kanály jsou ale lineární zobrazení z matic na matice, nikoli z vektorů na vektory, takže
jak obecně můžeme kanály vyjádřit matematicky? Někdy pro speciální kanály budeme mít jednoduchý vzorec,
který je popisuje, jako tomu bylo v příkladech qubit kanálů, které jsme již probrali. Ale to není
praktické obecně, protože ne vždy bude existovat takový pěkný vzorec. Jako srovnávací bod v zjednodušené
formulaci kvantové informace používáme unitární matice k reprezentaci operací na kvantových stavových vektorech.
Každá unitární matice reprezentuje platnou operaci a každou platnou operaci lze vyjádřit jako unitární matici. Takže
v podstatě tato otázka se ptá, jak to děláme pro kanály. Odpověď je, že ve skutečnosti existuje více způsobů, jak reprezentovat
kanály matematicky. Konkrétně probereme tři různé způsoby reprezentace kanálů,
pojmenované po třech osobnostech, jejichž práce hrála důležitou roli v jejich rozvoji: Stinespring, Krauss a Choi.
Nejprve uvidíme, jak tyto různé reprezentace fungují, a poté v poslední části lekce uvidíme, jak spolu tři reprezentace souvisejí a
zejména jak mezi nimi přecházet. Uvidíme také, že tyto reprezentace přesně zachycují požadavky, které máme na kanály,
konkrétně že jsou to lineární zobrazení a že vždy transformují hustotní matice na hustotní matice, i když
jsou aplikovány pouze na část složeného systému. Jako první jsou Stinespringovy reprezentace. Willam Forest Stine
spring byl matematik, který se nezabýval kvantovou informací, a Stinespringovy reprezentace, jak je popíši,
jsou v jistém smyslu jen derivátem jeho práce v teorii operátorů ze 50. let. Tato práce ale
byla bezpochyby důležitou součástí rozvoje matematiky, na níž jsou kvantové kanály založeny. Myšlenka za tímto způsobem reprezentace kanálů je, že každý
kanál lze implementovat určitým způsobem, který nyní popíši. Nejprve vytvoříme složený systém skládající se ze
vstupu jakéhokoli kanálu, který implementujeme, spolu s inicializovaným pracovním systémem. Poté je
na složeném systému provedena unitární operace a nakonec ta část výsledného složeného systému,
která odpovídá výstupu kanálu, je ponechána nebo vydána a zbytek je zahozen nebo vystopován. Je užitečné
vyjádřit to ve formě diagramu, a nejjednodušší je začít se speciálním případem, kdy jsou vstupní a
výstupní systémy stejné. Tento diagram je mimochodem stejný jako diagram kvantového circuit, s tím rozdílem, že dráty
reprezentují libovolné systémy a ne nutně jednotlivé qubity. Začínáme tedy se vstupním systémem X v nějakém
stavu ró, zavedeme inicializovaný pracovní systém W a v tomto diagramu předpokládám, že nula je klasický
stav W a bereme ket 0 jako inicializovaný stav systému. Alternativně bychom mohli zafixovat libovolný čistý stav
W a brát ho jako inicializovaný stav. Poté provedeme nějakou unitární operaci na páru WX a poté
vystopujeme pracovní systém a vydáme X. V diagramu mimochodem používám zemní symbol z
elektrotechniky k označení, že W je zahazováno. Není to nutně konvenční a v Qiskit tento symbol
nenajdeš: tam jednoduše ignoruješ qubity, o které nemáš zájem. Jde mi o to mít symbol, který dává jasně najevo,
že systém zahazujeme pro účely tohoto výkladu. Obecně nemusíme nutně požadovat, aby vstupní
a výstupní systémy byly stejné. Může nám tedy zbýt například výstupní systém Y spolu s odpadním
systémem G, který je vystopován. Aby bylo U unitární, musí být čtvercovou maticí, takže je zde předpoklad,
že pár GY dohromady má stejný počet klasických stavů jako pár WX. Například tyto systémy
mohou sestávat z qubitů a vstupní systém X může sestávat z 5 qubitů a W z 10 qubitů, takže U je unitární
operace na 15 qubitech. Pak Y může sestávat jen ze čtyř qubitů, což znamená, že G sestává z 11 qubitů.
Nebo to nemusejí být qubity vůbec – důležité je jen, aby WX dohromady a GY dohromady měly stejný počet
klasických stavů, aby U mohl být unitární. Popis kanálu tímto způsobem se nazývá Stinespringova reprezentace kanálu. Je
poměrně přímočaré argumentovat, že jakékoli zobrazení fí, které lze takto popsat, je ve skutečnosti platným kanálem.
Zejména pokud začneme s hustotní maticí a pak přidáme pracovní systém, jistě nám
zbyde hustotní matice. Již jsme pozorovali, že aplikace unitární operace nám dává platný kanál, a
pokud máme hustotní matici složeného systému a vystopujeme jeden ze systémů, opět nám zbyde hustotní matice. Takže když
tyto kroky složíme, budeme mít zaručeno, že vždy transformuje hustotní matice na hustotní matice, a je to také lineární.
V tomto okamžiku vůbec není jasné, že každý kanál lze skutečně implementovat tímto způsobem pro nějakou volbu
pracovního systému, odpadního systému a unitární operace U. Ale to je pravda a
uvidíme proč na konci lekce. Zde je příklad Stinespringovy reprezentace pro úplně
defázovací qubit kanál. Nyní jsou dráty qubity a jde o obyčejnou řízenou
operaci NOT (CNOT). Je velmi jednoduché: vstupní qubit je nahoře a zavedeme pracovní qubit inicializovaný do nulového
stavu. Poté provedeme operaci CNOT, kde vstupní qubit je řídicí a pracovní qubit je
cíl, a pak je pracovní qubit vystopován. Intuitivně dává smysl,
že by to mělo implementovat úplně defázovací kanál, protože operace CNOT se chová trochu jako standardní bázové měření na horním
qubitu kopírováním jeho klasického stavu na dolní qubit a poté se výsledek zahodí.
Můžeme ale také projít výpočtem a samozřejmě je dobré to udělat, protože bychom
WEBVTT
neměli příliš důvěřovat naší intuici. Můžeme začít zápisem hustotní maticové reprezentace
dvou qubitů poté, co byl zaveden pracovní qubit, a všimni si, že používáme Qiskit konvenci uspořádání qubitů,
kde dolní qubit je levý a horní qubit je vpravo. Tuto hustotní matici
můžeme zapsat explicitně jako skutečnou matici 4x4, jak je zobrazeno na obrazovce, a pak spočítáme efekt,
který má gate CNOT na tuto hustotní matici. Konjugujeme tedy unitární maticí spojenou s tímto
gate, opět s ohledem na Qiskit konvenci uspořádání, takže toto je správná unitární
matice a výsledek je zobrazen zde. Gate CNOT v podstatě
permutoval prvky naší původní matice, takže nyní jsou potenciálně nenulové prvky ve
čtyřech rozích. Zbývá spočítat parciální stopu a mohli bychom to udělat přímo z matice, ale
alternativou je převod na přímou notaci, jak je zobrazeno na obrazovce, a poté je poměrně snadné vyhodnotit,
co se stane, když vystopujeme qubit vlevo v každém výrazu, a výsledkem je, že přežijí jen
výrazy odpovídající diagonálním prvkům ró, a tedy jsme qubit defázovali,
jak se očekávalo. Jako vždy si to v klidu ověř sám, pokud se tak rozhodneš. Je to dobrý
příklad pro procvičení práce s hustotními maticemi a s parciálními
stopami. To není jediný způsob, jak implementovat úplně defázovací kanál. Zde je alternativní Stinespringova reprezentace pro tento
kanál. V tomto videu nepůjdu výpočtem podrobně, ale krátce ho ukážu pro případ, že bys chtěl video
pozastavit a lépe se podívat. Způsob, jak funguje, je podobný tomu prvnímu, ale podrobnosti jsou
jiné. Tentokrát začínáme s Hadamard gate na pracovním qubitu, který ho přivede do stavu plus. Pokud
rozvineme tenzorový součin, dostaneme matici zobrazenou na obrazovce. Pro aplikaci gate CZ
konjugujeme přidruženou unitární maticí a výsledkem je zavedení záporných znamének do
matice, konkrétně poslední řádek a poslední sloupec jsou vynásobeny minus 1.
Tentokrát by bylo dost složité převádět na přímou notaci, takže parciální stopu
spočítáme přímo. Když vystopujeme první ze dvou qubitů, dostaneme součet dvou diagonálních bloků 2x2
a konečným výsledkem je opět, že jsme qubit defázovali. Bylo to rychlé, a pokud nejsi zvyklý
na tyto druhy výpočtů, dej si čas a dělej to pomalu. Rychlost není důležitá.
Na závěr tohoto příkladu bych rád zmínil, že za touto implementací stojí poměrně jednoduchá myšlenka,
která je pěkně vyjádřena posledním krokem výpočtu, který jsme právě prolétli. Stručnější způsob, jak to říci,
je, že pokud průměrujeme danou hustotní matici qubitu s touto hustotní maticí konjugovanou maticí Pauli Z, pak
to je totéž jako defázování. Takže úplně defázovací kanál je smíšeným unitárním
kanálem, kde buď nic neděláme, neboli jinak řečeno provedeme identitní operaci, nebo provedeme gate Z, každé
s pravděpodobností 1/2. Dobré vědět. Takže celkově máme dvě různé
Stinespringovy reprezentace úplně defázovacího kanálu, a to nám říká něco důležitého, a sice, že Stinespringovy reprezentace jsou
nejednoznačné, a ve skutečnosti jich existuje nekonečně mnoho pro jakýkoli daný kanál. Dále probereme Kraussovy
reprezentace kanálů, které nám dávají pohodlný vzorcový způsob vyjádření kanálů pomocí maticového
násobení a sčítání. Kraussovy reprezentace jsou pojmenovány po Karlu Kraussovi, fyzikovi, který mimo jiné
propracoval mnoho základních matematických podrobností kanálů a obecné formulace kvantové informace šíře. Obecně je
Kraussova reprezentace vyjádřením kanálu ve tvaru zobrazeném zde na obrazovce. Konkrétně máme kolekci matic,
zde nazvaných A nula až A N minus jedna pro nějaké kladné celé číslo n, a ty specifikují
akci kanálu na libovolném vstupu ró podle vzorce. Stručně řečeno, konjugujeme ró každou z těchto matic,
které se v tomto kontextu nazývají Kraussovy matice, a pak výsledky sečteme, čímž dostaneme výstup. Všechny tyto matice musejí mít
stejné rozměry, a konkrétně jejich sloupce musejí odpovídat klasickým stavům vstupního systému a
řádky musejí odpovídat klasickým stavům výstupního systému. Pokud tomu tak je, pak pro libovolnou volbu K dostaneme ze součinu AK krát ró krát AK dagger čtvercovou matici,
jejíž řádky a sloupce odpovídají klasickým stavům výstupního systému,
a tak dává smysl, že výraz produkuje hustotní matici výstupního systému. Není pravda,
že pro libovolnou volbu Kraussových matic dostaneme platný kanál. Existuje však poměrně jednoduchá
podmínka na matice, která zaručuje, že dostaneme platný kanál, a tato podmínka je vzorec zobrazený zde.
Konkrétně pokud sečteme součin AK dagger krát AK přes všechny hodnoty K,
musíme dostat identitní matici, a to bude identitní matice, jejíž řádky a sloupce odpovídají
klasickým stavům vstupního systému. Tato podmínka tedy musí být splněna, aby zobrazení definované
první rovnicí bylo platným kanálem, a ukáže se, že každý kanál má ve skutečnosti reprezentaci tohoto tvaru,
pokud vezmeme n dostatečně velké. Zde je několik příkladů Kraussových
reprezentací, počínaje qubit reset channelem. Kraussovu reprezentaci pro tento kanál lze získat pomocí
dvou Kraussových matic: ket 0 bra 0 a ket 0 bra 1, takže n se rovná dvěma v tomto příkladu.
Tyto volby můžeme dosadit do obecného vzorce a máme jen dva výrazy, takže je snadné zapsat součet,
a pokud zjednodušíme a rozpoznáme, že výraz v závorce je stopa ró, vidíme, že dostaneme
qubit reset channel. Můžeme také ověřit, že požadovaná podmínka na tyto matice je splněna, a to je jednoduché dosazení Kraussových
matic do rovnice a vyhodnocení. Dostaneme identitní matici, jak je požadováno. Pro další příklad se znovu podívejme na
úplně defázovací kanál. Matice ket 0 bra 0 a ket 1 bra 1 fungují a lze to ověřit
rozvinutím součtu a přímým zjištěním, že dostaneme, co potřebujeme. Požadovaná podmínka je opět splněna.
Alternativou je vzít A nula jako identitní matici děleno odmocninou ze 2 a A1 jako
Sigma Z děleno odmocninou ze 2, a pokud to vyhodnotíme, opět dostaneme úplně defázovací kanál na základě pozorování,
WEBVTT
které jsme o tomto kanálu učinili trochu dříve v lekci, a opět je požadovaná podmínka poměrně přímočará
k ověření jako cvičení, které by ti mohlo přijít vhod. Uvažujme nyní úplně depolarizující
kanál, který vydává úplně smíšený stav pro každý vstup hustotní matice. Pro tento kanál jsou potřeba čtyři Kraussovy matice,
není možné přijít s Kraussovou reprezentací, kde n je tři nebo méně. Zde je jedna volba, která funguje,
a zde je další. Cvičení spočívá v ověření, že tyto volby fungují, a v ověření, že požadovaná podmínka
je splněna. Stojí za povšimnutí, že druhá alternativa v podstatě říká, že je možné úplně depolarizovat qubit, neboli jinými slovy
ho úplně znáhodnit, náhodným výběrem jedné ze čtyř Pauliho matic včetně identity a aplikací
odpovídající unitární operace na qubit. Takže úplně depolarizující kanál je dalším příkladem smíšeného
unitárního kanálu. Posledním ze tří pokrytých reprezentací kanálů je Choiova reprezentace. Man-Duen Choi
je matematik zabývající se teorií matic a dalšími tématy a Choiova reprezentace je pojmenována na jeho počest
na základě opravdu elegantního článku, který publikoval v roce 1975, jež v jistém smyslu vše spojuje dohromady. Choiova
reprezentace kanálu fí je jedinou maticí, konvenčně označovanou J fí, a konkrétně pokud má
vstupní systém n klasických stavů a výstupní systém M klasických stavů, pak Choiova reprezentace fí bude
čtvercová matice n krát M krát n krát M. Než ti povím přesně, jak je matice definována, rád bych zmínil pár
jejích klíčových vlastností, které motivují reprezentaci způsobem, který samotná definice nemusí, přinejmenším na
první pohled. Za prvé, na rozdíl od Stinespringových i Kraussových reprezentací je Choiova reprezentace
tzv. věrnou reprezentací, což znamená, že každý kanál má právě jednu. To je poměrně důležité,
protože to říká, že dva kanály jsou stejné právě tehdy a jen tehdy, pokud jejich Choiovy reprezentace jsou stejné. Takže pokud
máš dva různé popisy kanálů, jako jsou dvě různé Stinespringovy reprezentace nebo dvě různé Kraussovy reprezentace, nebo třeba jednu
z každé, a chceš vědět, zda jsou to ve skutečnosti stejné kanály, stačí spočítat Choiovu reprezentaci a
zkontrolovat, zda jsou nebo nejsou si rovny. Druhou vlastností jsou jednoduché podmínky pro Choiovu reprezentaci, které platí právě tehdy a jen tehdy,
když máme platný kanál. Tato vlastnost není tak zvláštní, totéž bychom mohli říci o ostatních dvou reprezentacích, ale je to dobrá vlastnost
přesto a níže se jí budeme věnovat podrobněji. Ještě jedna věc k Choiově reprezentaci: ačkoli kanál
reprezentujeme maticí, tato matice přímo nepředstavuje kanál jako lineární zobrazení. Přirozenější je
spojovat Choiovu reprezentaci s hustotní maticí, která reprezentuje určitý stav,
než ji považovat za popis lineárního zobrazení. Je však možné z Choiovy reprezentace
obnovit akci kanálu pomocí poměrně jednoduchého vzorce, ale není tak jednoduchý jako obyčejné maticové
násobení. Dost úvodu, pojďme k samotné definici. Předpokládejme, že máme kanál fí ze systému X do systému Y
a předpokládejme, že klasická stavová sada vstupního systému X je Sigma. Není třeba odkazovat na klasickou stavovou sadu výstupního systému, takže
pro definici ji nemusíme pojmenovávat. Choiova reprezentace fí je pak definována výrazem
zobrazeným zde na obrazovce. Máme součet přes všechny klasické stavy A a B pro vstupní systém a sčítáme ket A bra B
tenzorovaný s kanálem fí aplikovaným na ket A bra B. Tato
reprezentace je definována vzorcem a existuje pár různých způsobů, jak o tomto vzorci přemýšlet. Než je proberu, rád bych
zmínil, že Choiova reprezentace je někdy definována mírně odlišným způsobem, kde je pořadí dvou tenzorových faktorů obráceno, to znamená,
že fí z ket A bra se objevuje jako první tenzorový faktor, nikoli druhý. Oba způsoby jsou ale
ekvivalentní díky této jednoduché symetrii. To ale znamená, že při použití této reprezentace je dobré
vyjasnit, které uspořádání používáš. Toto uspořádání je způsobem, jak se to dělá v Qiskit, a je také lepší pro
vizuální popis reprezentace pomocí blokových matic. Proto s tímto uspořádáním budeme pracovat. Abychom byli přesnější ohledně popisu blokové matice,
pokud předpokládáme, že klasická stavová sada Sigma sestává z celých čísel od nuly do n minus jedna
pro nějaké kladné celé číslo n, pak J fí lze alternativně zapsat jako blokovou matici, jak je zobrazeno zde na
obrazovce. Jinými slovy, Choiova reprezentace fí je matice, kterou dostaneme vyhodnocením fí na každé ze
vstupních matic, která mají přesně jeden prvek rovný jedné a všechny ostatní nule, a pak je
přirozeným způsobem uspořádáme do matice. Nemusí být a priori jasné, proč bychom chtěli takovou matici tvořit, ale ukáže se,
že je velmi užitečná. Jedna věc, která si zaslouží pozornost, je, že množina obsahující matice ket A bra B, kde
A i B procházejí všemi celými čísly od 0 do n minus jedna, tvoří bázi prostoru všech matic n krát n. Takže pokud
tuto matici máš, můžeš jistě určit, co fí dělá s libovolnou maticí n krát n pomocí linearity,
konkrétně vhodnou lineární kombinací bloků. Matice J fí tedy jednoznačně
určuje fí jako lineární zobrazení. Dalším způsobem, jak přemýšlet o Choiově reprezentaci kanálu, je, že
reprezentuje stav jako hustotní matici po normalizaci, konkrétně dělením počtem
klasických stavů vstupního systému, který budu nadále označovat malým n. To nám vždy dá
hustotní matici, která se často nazývá Choiův stav kanálu. Zde je podrobněji, jak to funguje.
Představ si nejprve, že máme dvě identické kopie vstupního systému a uvažujeme kvantový stavový vektor s
zobrazený na obrazovce, který představuje tzv. maximálně splétaný stav tohoto páru identických systémů.
Například pokud je Sigma binární abeceda, pak je to stav fí plus, ale analogicky definovaný stav si lze představit pro
jakoukoli volbu Sigma, a dostaneme stav, který je silně splétaný, a ve skutečnosti splétaný co nejvíce,
jak jen lze pro tuto volbu systémů. Abychom dostali hustotní maticovou reprezentaci stavu, násobíme stavový vektor jeho konjugovaným transpozitem jako obvykle, a
takto to vypadá. Nakonec, pokud o Choiově reprezentaci kanálu dělené n přemýšlíme, vidíme, že je to stav,
který bychom dostali, kdybychom aplikovali kanál fí na druhý systém ve formě obrázku. Zde je
to, jak to vypadá: máme dvě kopie systému X v tomto maximálně splétaném stavu s. Kanál fí je
aplikován na druhý systém, který je v diagramu nahoře, a výsledný stav je Choiův stav fí. Samozřejmě bychom normálně
nedávali stejný název dvěma různým systémům, obecně není užitečné dávat stejný název dvěma různým věcem, ale v tomto případě to smysl dává,
WEBVTT
právě pro toto propojení s Choiovými reprezentacemi. Z tohoto pohledu na Choiovy reprezentace lze okamžitě vyvodit pár důsledků.
Jedním je, že protože Choiův stav je hustotní matice (za předpokladu, že fí je
platný kanál), dospíváme k závěru, že Choiova reprezentace fí musí být pozitivně semidefinitní. Pamatuj, že
je to požadavek, který klademe na kanály, konkrétně, že vždy transformují hustotní matice na hustotní matice, a to
je jen jeden zvláštní případ tohoto požadavku. Druhým důsledkem je, že pokud vezmeme Choiův stav libovolného kanálu fí a
poté zahodíme výstupní systém Y, musíme nám zbýt úplně smíšený stav na vstupním systému X.
Je to proto, že aplikovat kanál na systém a pak výsledný systém zahodit je ekvivalentní pouhému zahození původního systému,
a kdybychom to udělali s naším maximálně splétaným stavem, hustotní matice, která by nám zbyla, by byla
identitní matice dělená n, neboli jinými slovy úplně smíšený stav pro systém X. Myšlenka
vyjádřena matematicky je, že složení libovolného kanálu se stopou na výstupním systému musí být rovno stopě na
vstupním systému, a to proto, že kanály musejí zachovávat stopu na základě toho, že jsou lineárními zobrazeními, která
vždy transformují hustotní matice na hustotní matice. Jakmile máme tuto rovnici, můžeme odstraní jmenovatel n
z obou stran a dostat mírně čistší podmínku. Řečeno slovy: provedení parciální stopy na výstupním systému
Choiovy reprezentace kanálu nám musí dát identitní matici na vstupním systému. Stručně řečeno, Choiovy
reprezentace kanálů jsou vždy pozitivně semidefinitní, a pokud vystopujeme výstupní systém, nutně nám
zbyde identitní matice na vstupním systému. Jak se ukáže, toto nejsou jen nutné podmínky, ale
jsou i postačující, což znamená, že pokud fí je libovolné lineární zobrazení a tyto dvě podmínky jsou obě
splněny, pak fí musí být platným kanálem, a proč tomu tak je, uvidíme na konci lekce.
Podívejme se na pár příkladů, počínaje úplně defázovacím kanálem. Pro výpočet Choiovy reprezentace stačí
vyhodnotit vzorec. Úplně defázovací kanál ponechá ket A bra B beze změny, pokud A se rovná B, jinak je výstup
nula. Takže výrazy v součtu, které přežijí, jsou ty, kde A se rovná B, a výsledek je vyjádřen na
obrazovce pomocí přímé notace. Můžeme ho také zobrazit jako blokovou matici. Delta ponechává diagonální prvky beze změny a vynuluje mimediagonální
prvky, a tak nám zbývá matice s jedničkami v levém horním a pravém dolním rohu, přičemž všechny ostatní
prvky jsou nulové, a to je konzistentní s prvním vyjádřením. Pro další příklad uvažujme úplně depolarizující kanál. Opět
můžeme začít zapsáním vzorce a stejně jako v předchozím příkladu nedostaneme žádný příspěvek do součtu,
když A se nerovná B, a tentokrát, když A se rovná B, dostaneme úplně smíšený stav, který můžeme zjednodušit na
1/2 krát identitní matice 2x2 tenzorovaná sama se sebou, což je 1/2 krát identitní matice 4x4.
Můžeme o tom také přemýšlet pomocí blokových matic a přirozeně dostaneme stejný výsledek. A jako
poslední příklad uvažujme identitní kanál pro jeden qubit. Je to jednoduché: zde je vzorec a
identitní kanál samozřejmě nic nedělá. Výsledek si lze představit jako dvojnásobek hustotní matice asociované se stavem fí plus, a to
je konzistentní s tím, co očekáváme přemýšlením o Choiově stavu tohoto kanálu. A zde je výsledek jako bloková matice. Všimni si zejména, že Choiova
reprezentace identitního kanálu není identitní matice – je to tato matice. Nyní jsme viděli tři různé
způsoby, jak reprezentovat kanály matematicky, konkrétně Stinespringovy reprezentace, Kraussovy reprezentace a Choiovy
reprezentace. Máme také definici kanálu, která říká, že kanál je lineární zobrazení, které vždy
transformuje hustotní matice na hustotní matice, dokonce i tehdy, když je kanál aplikován jen na část složeného systému. Přirozenou a velmi důležitou
otázkou v tomto okamžiku je, jak víme, že tyto věci jsou všechny ekvivalentní. Například jak víme, že každé
zobrazení popsané kteroukoli z těchto reprezentací je ve skutečnosti platným kanálem, a jak víme, že žádné kanály nevynecháváme? Zbytek
lekce popisuje, jak o tom všem lze matematicky usuzovat. Pokud jsi ochoten přijmout ekvivalenci těchto věcí a nezajímá tě, jak se to zdůvodňuje,
klidně přeskoč zbytek videa. Já osobně si ale myslím, že argument je poměrně
elegantní a je dobrým příkladem určitého stylu matematického důkazu, který se čas od času v teorii kvantové informace vyskytuje. Nepůjdu
přes všechny podrobnosti – některé nechám na tobě, nebo je najdeš v písemném obsahu pro tuto lekci, kde je vše sepsáno
podrobně. Doufám ale, že předložím přiměřeně jasný obraz, jak to celé funguje. Naším cílem je dokázat
ekvivalenci souboru tvrzení, a způsob, jak to udělat, je nastavit cyklus implikací. Konkrétně začneme
s definicí kanálu, tedy lineárního zobrazení, které vždy transformuje hustotní matice na hustotní matice.
Z této definice lze odvodit, že Choiova reprezentace tohoto kanálu musí splňovat dvě podmínky, které jsme
již identifikovali, a ve skutečnosti jsme to již udělali – bylo to diskutováno v kontextu Choiova stavu kanálu. Pak
zapomeneme na definici a pracujeme z Choiovy reprezentace, a ze dvou podmínek pro Choiovy reprezentace dospíváme k závěru, že musí existovat
Kraussova reprezentace zobrazení fí. Poté uděláme analogickou věc – zapomeneme na Choiovy reprezentace a pracujeme
z libovolné Kraussovy reprezentace, a z ní odvodíme, že musí existovat Stinespringova reprezentace zobrazení fí. Mimochodem, tyto
argumenty budou v jistém smyslu mechanické, což nám umožňuje skutečně provádět převody podle šipek pro konkrétní kanály, pokud
to chceme. Poslední implikací je odvodit, že pokud máme Stinespringovu reprezentaci zobrazení fí, pak
toto zobrazení musí být platným kanálem, a to jsme již udělali – v kontextu Stinespringových
reprezentací. Celkově tyto čtyři implikace odhalují, že tyto čtyři věci jsou všechny ekvivalentní, protože od ktérekoli z nich
lze implikace tranzitivně sledovat, abychom se dostali ke ktérekoli z ostatních. Začneme první implikací,
totiž že pokud máme kanál fí, tedy lineární zobrazení, které vždy transformuje hustotní matice na hustotní matice, pak má Choiovu
reprezentaci splňující dvě podmínky, které jsme dříve identifikovali, konkrétně, že je pozitivně semidefinitní
a že pokud vystopujeme výstupní systém, dostaneme identitu na vstupním systému. A jak jsem před chvílí zmínil, tuto
implikaci jsme již pokryli v kontextu Choiových stavů. Zejména, když vydělíme Choiovu reprezentaci kanálu n, počtem
klasických stavů vstupního systému, dostaneme hustotní matici a navíc redukovaný stav
vstupního systému X pro tento stav je úplně smíšený stav, neboli jinými slovy identitní matice dělená n. Odstraněním jmenovatele dostaneme naše
dvě podmínky, takže tato implikace je poměrně rychlá a snadná, protože jsme ji již pokryli.
WEBVTT
Nyní se podívejme na druhou implikaci. Tentokrát začínáme s Choiovou reprezentací zobrazení,
o níž předpokládáme, že splňuje oba požadavky, a naším cílem je přijít s Kraussovou reprezentací pro toto zobrazení, která
splňuje požadavek, o němž jsme mluvili dříve. Tato implikace je v jistém smyslu dost mechanická – budeme potřebovat
trochu lineární algebry a vše se bude hlavně scvrkávat na manipulaci s maticemi a vektory dost chytrým
způsobem. Začíná předpokladem, že Choiova reprezentace je pozitivně semidefinitní, což je první ze dvou podmínek,
které předpokládáme. Pojem pozitivně semidefinitní matice je fundamentálně důležitý v kvantové informaci nejen v kontextu hustotních
matic – je zde absolutně kritický. Bez něj bychom to nedokázali. Zejména předpoklad,
že J fí je pozitivně semidefinitní, nám umožňuje vyjádřit ji ve tvaru zobrazeném na obrazovce pro nějakou volbu
vektorů s0 až S N minus jedna a nějakou volbu kladného celého čísla n. Explicitně poznamenávám, že to nejsou
nutně jednotkové vektory. Jedním způsobem, jak takový výraz získat, je spektrální věta pro pozitivně
semidefinitní matice, o níž se diskutovalo v předchozí lekci. Zde nevidíme žádné vlastní hodnoty explicitně jako ve spektrálním
rozkladu, ale pamatuj, že vlastní hodnoty pozitivně semidefinitních matic jsou vždy nezáporná reálná čísla, a mějme také na paměti, že
nevyžadujeme, aby tyto vektory s0 až S N minus jedna byly jednotkovými vektory. Takže co můžeme udělat, je vzít odmocniny
vlastních hodnot a vynásobit jimi jednotkové vlastní vektory ze spektrálního rozkladu, abychom dostali tyto
vektory s0 až S N minus jedna. Ve skutečnosti pro tento důkaz není důležité, aby tyto vektory byly ortogonální – dostaneme to
ze spektrálního rozkladu, ale zde to nepoužíváme. A pokud bychom měli jiný výraz pro J fí tohoto tvaru, který nepochází ze spektrálního
teorému, bylo by to také v pořádku. Nyní každý z těchto vektorů rozložíme tak, jak je zobrazeno na obrazovce, a
to je stejné, jako bychom dělali, kdyby tyto vektory byly kvantovými stavovými vektory páru systémů XY a prováděli
standardní bázové měření na systému X. Aby bylo jasno, zde nic neměříme, jen zapisujeme tyto vektory v tomto tvaru, což
je vždy možné. A nyní přichází ten trik: definujeme Kraussovy matice A0 až A N minus jedna vytrháním K-tých
A z přední části těchto vektorů s0 až S N minus jedna, jejich otočením, aby se staly bra A místo ket A,
a přilepením doprava, jak je zobrazeno v rovnici na obrazovce. Jeden způsob, jak o tom přemýšlet,
je, že vlastně tyto vektory skládáme, abychom vytvořili matice, takže kdybychom sloupcové vektory AK naskládali na sebe, dostali bychom
zpět s. Tyto matice tedy mají přesně stejné prvky jako odpovídající vektory, jen jsme je
přeuspořádali, abychom dostali matice. O těchto maticích ale také můžeme přemýšlet čistě symbolicky v pojmech přímé notace,
jak je napsáno zde. A nyní v tomto okamžiku vyvstává zřejmá otázka: proč by to mělo fungovat? Nezdržujme se příliš
přemýšlením nad tím, proč to funguje – ověřme si, že to funguje. Za tím účelem si definujme nové zobrazení, které je definováno
pomocí těchto matic, kde je považujeme za Kraussovy matice. Co nyní můžeme udělat, je spočítat Choiovu reprezentaci
tohoto nového zobrazení a uvidíme, že se rovná Choiově reprezentaci zobrazení fí, se kterým jsme začali, a
protože Choiovy reprezentace jsou věrné, to znamená, že tato dvě zobrazení jsou ve skutečnosti stejná. V tomto videu algebru neprojdu,
můžeš si to ověřit sám, je to dost mechanické a dobré cvičení, a vše, co k tomu potřebuješ, je právě
zde na obrazovce. Dosud jsme nic neřekli o druhé podmínce ve dvou rámečcích, ale
ukazuje se, že jsou ekvivalentní, a jedním způsobem, jak to doložit, je ověřit rovnici zobrazenou zde dole na
obrazovce. Písmeno T zde mimochodem odkazuje na transpozici matice, o níž můžeš alternativně přemýšlet jako o
lineárním zobrazení, které převádí ket A bra B na ket B bra A, a je to jen něco, co je potřeba pro správné fungování vzorce. Takže celkově
je pro tuto implikaci jistě potřeba trochu algebry, ale jak jsem řekl, je to všechno dost mechanické,
základně jsou to indexové manipulace, jak to někteří nazývají. Pokud se ale přes to prokousáš a dáš svému mozku šanci to strávit, možná zjistíš,
že lépe pochopíš, jak spolu Choiovy a Kraussovy reprezentace souvisejí. Třetí implikace nám umožňuje
přejít z Kraussovy reprezentace zobrazení fí, kde je zavedena obvyklá podmínka, na Stinespringovu reprezentaci. Tato
je duchem dost podobná předchozí v tom smyslu, že je mechanická a lze ji zobrazit a ověřit v čistě algebraickém smyslu.
Myšlenka je ve skutečnosti poměrně jednoduchá: vezmeme naše Kraussovy matice a vytvoříme část větší matice jejich naskládáním
na sebe, jak je zobrazeno na obrazovce. Jakmile je vyplněna, dá nám to unitární matici U pro
Stinespringovu reprezentaci. Unitární matice musejí být čtvercové, takže budeme muset doplnit tolik zbývajících
sloupců, kolik potřebujeme, ale nezáleží na tom, jaké jsou, pokud dostaneme unitární
matici. Pokud dočasně odložíme obavu, zda je U unitární, a soustředíme se jen na lineární zobrazení definované
Stinespringovou reprezentací, kterou z této matice U dostaneme, zjistíme, že toto zobrazení se rovná
původnímu zobrazení fí definovanému Kraussovou reprezentací, se kterou jsme začali. To je další část důkazu, kterou v tomto videu neprojdu,
podrobnosti najdeš v písemném obsahu pro tuto lekci, ale možná si raději dáš čas a sám se tím prokousáš. Jen
mějme na paměti, jak je zvykem v sérii, že pro interpretaci diagramu používáme Qiskit konvenci uspořádání, takže W a G budou
odpovídat tenzorových faktorům na levé straně v rovnicích. Mimochodem, pokud tím
procházíš, zjistíš, že protože máme ket 0 bra 0 jako tenzorový faktor na levé straně v rovnici,
jedinou relevantní částí U je část daná Kraussovými maticemi. Takže dokud doplníme sloupce U způsobem, který ho učiní unitárním,
je vše v pořádku. To samozřejmě vyžaduje, aby sloupce tvořené A0 až A N minus jedna naskládanými na sebe
byly ortonormální, a právě zde vstupuje podmínka, kterou klademe na Kraussovy reprezentace.
A ta je přesně ekvivalentní ortonormalitě sloupců. Příslušné matematické vztahy potřebné k vyvození tohoto
závěru jsou zobrazeny zde dole na obrazovce, takže si je pauzuj a ověř, pokud chceš, nebo opět
konzultuj písemný obsah pro další podrobnosti. Stručně řečeno, v obou těchto implikacích i té předchozí
popisujeme tytéž matematické operace různými, ale ekvivalentními způsoby. Bijícím srdcem
toho všeho je v podstatě maticové násobení. Čtvrtá a poslední implikace stanovuje, že pokud máme
Stinespringovu reprezentaci pro nějaké zobrazení, pak toto zobrazení musí být platným kanálem, a jak jsem uvedl
dříve, tuto implikaci jsme již pokryli, když jsme diskutovali Stinespringovy reprezentace. Stručně a
WEBVTT
jinými slovy: zavedení inicializovaného pracovního systému je platný kanál, protože tenzorové násobení pevnou
hustotní maticí k dané hustotní matici nám vždy dá hustotní matici a jde o lineární zobrazení díky bilinearitě
tenzorových součinů. Unitární operace jsou vždy platnými kanály, jak jsem diskutoval dříve v lekci. Stopování systému je platný kanál, protože parciální
stopa je lineární zobrazení, které vždy transformuje hustotní matice na hustotní matice. A konečně, složení
kanálů jsou vždy kanály, což je poměrně jednoduché, ale rozhodně stojí za povšimnutí samo o sobě. A se
čtyřmi implikacemi, které jsme právě pokryli, jsme dokázali ekvivalenci našich tří reprezentací kanálů spolu s
původní definicí kanálu. Zejména jsme začali s definicí kanálu, viděli jsme, jak tato definice implikuje, že jeho Choiova
reprezentace nutně splňuje dvě základní podmínky, a poté jsme viděli, jak nám tyto podmínky umožňují najít Kraussovu reprezentaci, která nám zase
umožňuje najít Stinespringovu reprezentaci, a nakonec jsme viděli, že existence Stinespringovy reprezentace odhaluje, že máme
skutečně platný kanál. Samozřejmě jsou v tom technické podrobnosti a není to nutně jednoduché, zvláště
když to vidíš poprvé. Ale co je zajímavé a pozoruhodné, je, že tyto implikace jsou nastaveny způsobem, který
skutečně usnadňuje věci co nejvíce, a v matematice bys nikdy neměl pociťovat stud za to, že jdeš
snadnější cestou. Například vůbec není zřejmé, že každý kanál má Stinespringovu reprezentaci nebo Kraussovu reprezentaci,
ale je poměrně snadné dospět k závěru, že Choiova reprezentace každého kanálu splňuje dvě podmínky, které jsme s ní spojili, a to
nám umožňuje sledovat více méně algebraickou cestu k ostatním dvěma reprezentacím. Podobně je poslední
implikace ze Stinespringovy reprezentace zpět k definici také relativně přímočará a umožňuje nám
dospět k závěru, že z Choiových reprezentací dostaneme pouze kanály a žádná jiná zobrazení, za předpokladu, že jsou
splněny požadované podmínky. A jak jsem naznačil dříve, způsob, jakým tyto implikace zdůvodňujeme, je dostatečně mechanický, abychom mohli snadno přecházet
mezi reprezentacemi, a pokud se vrátíš k některým příkladům, které jsme probírali dříve v lekci, zjistíš, že je skutečně možné
mezi reprezentacemi přecházet, někdy docela snadno a přímo. A to je konec
lekce, která byla celá o kanálech. Mluvili jsme o tom, co jsou, a podívali jsme se na některé základní příklady. Probrali jsme tři způsoby, jakými lze kanály
reprezentovat, a ponořili jsme se do technických podrobností, které dokazují ekvivalenci těchto reprezentací.
Doufám, že se přidáš k příští lekci, která se celá věnuje měřením v obecné formulaci kvantové informace. Na shledanou!